no
so you want him to be again disgust
factor i'm not here for it i'm i'm from
zimbabwe i came here when i was 14. so i
grew up on like when you watch an advert
there's like an ads aids
campaign video something like oh you
have to get your partner tested so it's
like ingrained in me like i'm not here
for that i don't want to like
ask you can you go to the clinic and get
checked as long as i'm not here for that
let's let's say you like him and you
trust him right you trust his word so if
he says okay like i'll always use
protection i'd never put you at risk
right
but obviously
understand it's amazing that you know
you've done that for yourself but
obviously the average person that we
live in very different times right now
that's why i won't ask him to do
something in this level that i can't do
like to me it's like a self-control
problem
for him
yeah
it's a heart it's a very hard sell i
think i know that's why it's difficult
because it's like saying because i think
it's like if he knows he's a like to be
with you he has to go vegan
yeah but the commitment doesn't start
like if you're quite traditional kim it
doesn't start till that rings on your
finger yeah not really yeah so until
that rings on your finger he's not
committed to you yeah getting to know
each other right yeah but you're saying
that even when he's not committed to you
you don't want him he want him to be i
would prefer that he doesn't do that i
know but is it a write-off for you
it would be that's a hard seller i know
can i no i'm well aware of that yeah so
um would you be would you marry a guy
quickly
so you he he's yeah
cause i know christian
i'm just saying quickly that's what
christians do all the time they'll get
married in like
okay
three months three months would you
marry that you just met them three
months later would you put it
it depends
yeah
i probably would okay i know people have
done it i probably but it really depends
on a lot of things okay yeah put a one
in the chat if you're trying to
would you also be open to um an arranged
marriage if your parents found someone
that that they could then bring you guys
together both i would only trust my dad
to do that i won't trust my mom i love i
love her but i wouldn't trust it to rage
yeah dad knows best have you dated
outside of the church or would you only
date a guy in the church i've dated
outside the church before yeah okay just
to see okay what is it like someone in
the chat said virgins tend to try to
date men who are bad boys or men outside
the church i don't like bad boys no okay
i've never liked bad boys i like it
sounds weird but i like squares i don't
like emotional anxiety from someone so
bad boys they bring anxiety i don't like
that okay okay fair enough that's that's
really good that's like very impressive
um i'm gonna read super chats for a
second you're gonna get all these people
in love with you
oh i can put up the chat oh yeah that's
great thank you can you just remind the
chat what the chart was okay guys so um
ish is going to show um the sexual
market value chart and this is a chart
made by rolo tomasi basically showing
um
men and women's value in the dating
market
so yeah this is what we were talking
about earlier if you guys wanted to see
it
do you want to talk us through it before
we read super chats or just um no i mean
i don't know what else what are we
talking about do you guys agree with the
chart like you would say at 22 is most
girls peak
yeah yeah 12. so 22 most girls people
okay would you say it would you
would you say you're left over by 35
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is the most
geriatric
geriatric pregnancy is like 35 or 37. i
think it depends
so for example my dad met my stepdad so
she met him when she was like 34 35
and they basically had a great you could
say marriage like 13 years before he
passed away last year but he was
literally the top tier guy
mechanic earning all that good money but
also taking care of the family and yeah
so i think
it just really depends on the person
but that's more the minority rather than
majority so i understand that too so yes
you we would say for the most part for
the most part yeah i think if you're um
i think if you're talking strictly
physically attractive
then
yeah
for i think for most women then yeah
they're probably gonna you know their
highest their peak the season of their
peak is going to be in their early to
mid 20s but
i think any man who is looking for a
partner knows that a woman's value isn't
just in her looks
and so if he's going to choose her
there has to be more than that and i
think
just in my experience
that
while they can be very attractive women
who are 22 23
a lot of them don't have
they haven't developed the mindset to be
a good partner yeah
um so
yeah as long as she's attractive fine
but yeah if we're talking strictly
physically attractive then yeah of
course my question to you then is that
don't you think if you find a woman that
is willing to be submissive to you you
can train her in the way you'd like her
to think in a certain way because at
that moment when she's being submissive
to you she's putting all her trust in
you and at that moment if she's putting
a trust in you then she'd be able to
listen to the things you say
do the things that you'd ask her to do
without
little to no questioning and so you can
find a woman at a certain age that you
like with the beauty that maybe you
missed out on with another woman yeah
yeah and then get one i think i think
there can be an element of that but i
think there's and this is why i think
men or masculine feminine complement
each other there are things that women
bring that men just don't are not aware
of they don't they like they don't
expect do you know what i mean so a
woman who has that natural initiative to
um
to
be an asset to her man's life in ways
that he does he didn't even realize she
could i think that's something only
women can know if i'm being honest i
think there's an element of you can you
know guide her to be the kind of partner
you want if she's younger but
regarding the training i don't know
maybe in western countries
that's that's not very appliable
nowadays because if you go to university
and you go around asking them questions
about modern dating whatever
you're not going to find someone who's
very
appliable to train based on how these
how they view things and talk and
whatever so you're going to have a
difficult time with that so i wouldn't
go to a university looking for that
person
but most of them were there like 21 most
likely that's where you would find a
bunch of them that is true i think more
so than anything you kind of have to
understand that
if you're looking to date a certain type
of person it's all about strategic
planning you need to position yourself
in a situation where you can find the
type of woman you're looking for now if
the type of woman i'm looking for and
i'm not saying i am personally no i'm
saying if the type of woman i'm looking
for is someone that um
is able to get on my page i probably
wouldn't go to university where
a lot of things are happening
um but it's just strategically where are
you positioning yourself to find the
type of women you like or as a woman i
say to my sister are you positioning
yourself
in the positions yeah to find the type
of men you want
so yeah yeah
okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
sec guys um if you have a comment that
you want read said send a super chat all
super chats are going towards studio
updates we want to get two more cameras
we talked about ish i think two yeah
more cameras yeah two more cameras i
know we got issue camera you guys are
excited
but we're gonna we're trying to get two
more just to get better angles on the
people over there like the far angle so
whoever sits there okay
[Music]